I hold an FPT to Nacional a tiara I told
her well you cannot combine please is
this your daughter Aliannah teleme see
a trip to Chile's high desert is the
perfect excuse to hang with someone like
Magdalena
she's a shaman who for a reasonable fee
offers up a soul cleanse
your spirit is healed as your brain
melts tiny thing is you know that we all
know after the ceremonial stripping of
the gringo and whatever this is
Magdalena forces me to drink an ungodly
amount of water you will start a new
relation with water so you will be clean
okay then she burns me into my wounds
she pours something called combo which
is a secretion that comes from a very
poisonous
Amazonian tree frog it's done don't
expect anything okay just be here
time is an illusion water is life and
that's when the frog juice really kicked
in
there was the desert
it was cruel and then it was kind there
were huge telescopes nestled up against
the heavens there were strange gurgling
pools full of minerals there was a
bustling city in a chair I could control
with my mind
it was a grand vision of what Chile had
to offer and what needed to be explored
or something like that yeah
[Music]